he is the aforementioned Randy Johnson
five times siyoung winter special
assistant to the Diamondbacks and he
joins us now Randy good morning thanks
for joining us it's Dan it's Dan Patrick
dan Patrick hold on let me look at my
schedule if I had you in my schedule day
all right yes yes great Randy how about
you not bad not bad what do you what do
you been doing since we last talked you
were in like Tokyo or something last
time we talked I've had a very busy
schedule the last uh last month I just
got back from Germany I flew on a USO
tour to go visit for military bases
outside of Frankfurt and then I went
after that was done I did a little bit
of meeting and greeting and got to meet
a lot of our soldiers our men and women
over there and then after that was done
then I flew to Munich because I heard
there was a beer festival over there
called Oktoberfest and so I didn't
necessarily go but you don't really need
to go because when you're in Munich it's
Oktoberfest everywhere you go so then I
got back last Wednesday I flew in from
Germany landed and then went right to
the ballpark to watch the wild card game
against the Rockies and so if it
appeared that I was sleepwalking or a
little bit of zombie like well then that
was my reason if I needed your for one
inning today can I count on you let me
get back to you on that after I've had
my red ball how fast you think you can
throw now not very you know I really
enjoy watching baseball now enjoy
talking baseball now I guess you know
when you're doing something
like I was for 22 years especially the
last portion of my career I'd say about
the last 15 years I really came into my
own I really felt like I had blinders on
and it may have been the reason why I
was really focused but it may have been
the reason why I shut a lot of other
stuff out you know not probably the best
in a lot of those areas but I look at
the game now and you know there's uh
there's there's the effort that has to
go into performing on a daily basis and
now we're in the playoffs so and I've
watched all the playoff games and you
know it's it's you as a starting pitcher
you go out there and you've had a great
year like say Kluber did or or sale and
you have your one opportunity to shine
and if you don't then it you know and
I've been there so I you know kind of
feel bad for those guys feel like you
know Robby ray are our left-handed
pitcher here in Arizona really was
probably better situated to pitch the
first game against Kershaw on regular
rest and all that he pitched in the in
the wild-card game a couple innings and
came back and you know that wasn't that
that's not indicative of how good of a
pitcher he is I would say he's probably
in the top four left-handed pitchers in
all of baseball I would put him that
high based on what I've seen you know
Kershaw obviously you know one and then
sail but I would I would put Robby ray
right there so I hope that you know we
got the proverbial backs against the
wall but so did the Yankees and Red Sox
I hope that we can you know be in home
today Greinke will pitch a masterful
game and that's why the Diamondbacks
went out and got him and then we'll take
tomorrow if it comes and when it comes
and but I'd really like to see I'd
really like to see people see the
Diamondbacks
how good they are I mean you know JD
Martinez has had a great year since he's
gotten traded from Detroit and
Goldschmidt and Lam and you got a lot of
maybe not household names throughout the
country but here in Arizona these guys
are really put a real good year together
and and really accumulated during the
course of season some big numbers and
you know it was just like when I played
in Seattle you know East Coast never saw
West Coast games because they'd already
be sleeping by the time our games are
starting I feel like you know a lot of
people really don't see the Diamondbacks
play that much and it's too bad that
because during the regular season you
know we really handled the Dodgers
pretty well especially our pitching so
today will be the day hopefully we get
things together and and to have a great
game all around do you understand or
relate to Kershaw great regular-season
struggling in the postseason I did I did
I think you know I think it may have
been what last year when he were the
year before when he lost a couple of
games and you know I was I guess he had
tied me you doing in in the in the games
that you pitched in postseason I guess I
went seven seven
I had seven losses consecutively until I
finally won and you know yes some of the
games were pretty ugly unfortunately but
you know when I went to Houston in in 98
and left Seattle and played to the
Houston Astros we played San Diego and
you know I lost a one-nothing game
against Kevin Brown and then lost and
then gave up a couple of runs in seven
days against early Hitchcock and lost
that game so but you know it doesn't
matter whether it's you know it well it
matters whether it's a good performance
or a bad performance but the bottom line
is you know you accumulate losses and
and that that's kind of like what I'm
saying you know when you have a regular
season and it's a stellar season now
you're you're going out there to pitch
one game and and you know after all the
or pictures you've thrown during the
regular season and the innings you know
you really got to be focused on every
pitch and its really it becomes just as
much of a mental game as it does
physical because you know you really
gotta think your way through every pitch
because every pitch is important you
know any run you'll give up could be the
deciding run we're talking to Randy
Johnson the Hall of Famer five times
siyoung winner is there a home run you
gave up where you just say how did that
guy take me deep northwood water oh that
one but but that was I just talked to
him a week ago Randy he brought that up
really yeah no I was I was in Germany I
think in Germany he said I said Mac
what's the one homerun you want me to
show that you know if I'm talking about
you and that kind of sums up your career
and he goes well the one off of Randy
and I go Randy Johnson and he goes yeah
that one yeah that was you know we were
we were teammates for a couple years at
USC and so we had a lot of battles uh
you know me pitching in Seattle for 10
years and him playing down Oakland
obviously in the same division played
Oakland a lot so it was a lot of fun
faced in the Oakland A's they had a
great team and that way that might have
been the reason why I developed a little
bit you know quicker because I was
playing against there's so many good
teams when I was playing you know you
just couldn't go out and be a one pitch
pitcher with a fastball so as my career
was developing I was developing more
pitches as well with a two seamer the
slider or a fastball and understand you
got to pitch both sides of the plate and
but you gave up a home run to a home run
hitter there has to be a guy right like
you know one of the great homerun
hitters of all time but there had to be
some who took you deep where you went
are you kidding me I mean heck I gave up
my share of homeruns and you know I'm
not really ashamed of I mean I'm I'm
disappointed that I gave up but you know
you you then if you're out there that is
low
as I've been out there and you're
throwing pictures you're bound to give
up your share of homeruns and I've given
up my share of of homeruns - homerun
hitters and then I've given up my share
of homeruns maybe people that you
wouldn't think would be hitting home
runs but you know it is what it is and
hell I even got a homerun in my career
who'd you get it off of an old teammate
of mine Doug Davis so guy yeah I know
after that a couple years later we ended
up becoming teammates and I ripped them
a little bit but I really find I really
find baseball at its most interesting
time right now because when you're in a
five-game series and and you kit and you
can have your your rotation lined up the
way you would like well that's one thing
but you know like for Cleveland example
everybody was expecting Kluber to start
then you had Bower and power went out
and dealt really well and beat the
Yankees and then you had Kluber Pitts
the next day and he didn't pitch as well
as I'm sure he would have liked to have
the team still won but had a little bit
of a hole to climb out but that's the
beauty of the game and you can't always
expect the expected in this game because
there's intangibles you got you know
make a bad pitch
err you know walked out batter hit a
batter something happens and in today's
game you know in the playoffs there's
been a lot of high-scoring games I mean
the only real well pitched game was the
one last night with our Cleveland and
New York and there's been so many
top-notch pitchers pitching in
postseason but they really haven't you
know pitched as well as they would like
to so I'm you know have been there
before on both sides of the track so
it's it's exciting but I'm pulling for
the Diamondbacks tonight
against the Dodgers and and hopefully we
get past tonight and we'll move on to
tomorrow great to talk to you as always
Randy have fun tonight and hopefully
we'll talk again soon all right Darren
take care that's Randy Johnson Hall of
Fame
five times saw a young winner and
special assistant to the Diamondbacks
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience